[Music]
well resale or thrifting as it's called
is a billion multi-billion dollar
industry that just keeps growing
according to the U.S Census Bureau it's
so popular all different ages and now
there's a new store to get in on that
Trend Candace Charles joining us live
from the new Goodwill it's on Las Vegas
Boulevard and Robindale uh Candace you
ready to pop those tags
I am honestly I've been looking at a lot
of stuff and so has Armando our
photographer there's some good finds
here you guys and whether it's social
media uh the eco-friendly or
sustainability benefits that come with
it or inflation thrifting is drawing
folks in now according to the National
Association of resale and thrift shops
about 16 to 17 percent of Americans shop
at thrift stores during the year now
that now they can go to a new Goodwill
store right here in southern Nevada the
17th store here in southern Nevada and
I'm joined by their Brian Stewart who
has all the tips and tricks on how to do
thrifting right tell us a little bit
about those tricks all right well trick
number one is all about how well we
organize everything on our floor so and
it really is organized you guys can see
the colors it's beautiful absolutely so
the item category the size and the color
it's all there so if you're zeroing in I
need a short sleeve blue dress boom it's
so easy to find in your size knife we
actually have one right behind us guys
and there's all different types of
Brands as well here you know it's not
just
um you know the everyday ones we're
actually that's a tour address there we
actually have some Anne Stewart I heard
as well and what are the things that
people should be looking for what are
those do well the deal always begins
first and foremost with dollar day so
every Monday is a dollar day where every
item in a single color tag is one dollar
that's like one dollar guys right and
that is the last day following six days
of fifty percent off in that color so we
call that a color tag of the week right
so the every day there is a deal also we
find seniors are attracted by our
discounts
um they are 20 off every day and then we
have double discount Wednesday where
it's forty percent off so yeah so you
see a lot of seniors the lines can get a
little bit long but for a good deal it's
worth the wait definitely absolutely
Brian thank you so much look for those
red tags you guys those are the ones
they're going to be giving you all the
deals I hope you were writing some of
that stuff of Doubt because there's
definitely a lot of days you can come
down here and save some money this new
store opens today at nine the first 100
folks that come through will be getting
a special prize a deal so we'll have
those details for you on our website
8newsnow.com come